denn es geht um frauen in der medizin
und mein credo ist dass frauen eine
andere eine bessere medizin brauchen und
das ist ziemlich erschüttern muss ich
sagen bei den recherchen zu meinem buch
habe ich festgestellt dass frauen
eigentlich ignoriert werden in der
forschung in der entwicklung von
medikamenten von diagnoseverfahren von
therapieverfahren der mensch gilt als
man das heißt das geht los bei
männlichen zellen mäusezellen bei der
erprobung von medikamenten geht dann
weiter über
die erprobung an männlichen mäusen
männlichen größeren tieren an dem man
wenn frauen einbezogen werden in studien
dann ist es meistens so dass sie die
ergebnisse nicht getrennt ausgewertet
werden was das zu was das dann führt ist
das wenn ein medikament zum beispiel auf
den markt kommt oder ein
diagnoseverfahren einen
therapieverfahren dann wird es bei uns
eigentlich erst ausprobiert und das
führt dazu dass frauen deutlich mehr
nebenwirkungen haben bei medikamenten
dass wir die oft nicht so gut wirken
dass die diagnoseverfahren nicht passen
und dass am ende auch mehr frauen
dadurch starben als männer und das ist
eine unglaubliche ungerechtigkeit wo ich
finde dass dem noch nicht genug rechnung
getragen wird wir brauchen diese
gerechtigkeit in forschung und in der
lehre das ist ganz ganz wichtig
tja also ich kann gar nicht
widersprechen weil sie natürlich als
erst mal kann ich eine einer ärztin
schon gar nicht widersprechen sagte
rubin wenn sie jetzt noch in weißem
kittel an hätten können
legen sie hier ja blatt aber jetzt kann
ich es auf wissenschaftlicher ebene gar
nicht
gar nicht beurteilen aber im vorgespräch
haben sie haben sie gesagt dass sie vor
allem die
naturheilkunde
mehr in den vordergrund stellen wollen
und da hatte ich da hab ich da hab ich
gedacht da möchte ich widersprechen wir
alles was wir gesagt haben können sie
jetzt könnt ihr aber mit zur
naturheilkunde und sein da der nächste
teil der gewesen wäre aber ich habe
gedacht wir haben uns das für eine
andere sendung mal auf ist dass ich
glaube dass sowohl die patienten wie
auch die ärzte wie auch unser
gesundheitssystem eine komplementäre
medizin braucht das heißt wir brauchen
die ergänzung aus schulmedizin
hochschulmedizin
komplementären erfahrung verfahren da
gehört auch die natur erkunden dazu und
einer ende evokation also belehrung
sozusagen in lebensstiländerung also
kleiner dabei kommt die leute nicht aber
genau das ist dagegen natur 100 jahren
spiel beim natur können wo sie denn dass
der einzige punkt wo ich wieder 100
leute haben doch einmal sicher deine
naturkunde dollar wie das einzige land
der welt wo es zum schamanen gehen kann
und auf der auf kosten der
solidargemeinschaft wird das wer das
bezahlt globuli ist der größte aber da
geht jetzt aber wenn ich höre was
unterschied aber da es ja gut also ich
habe jetzt muss ich halt und dass man
personen über das rege mich gerade ob
sarah über kriminelle einmal zu alena
weiter ich muss sagen ich finde es ganz
toll als frau dass dieses heute
mitgebracht haben weil ich ja wobei mir
auch schon ganz viele gedanken gemacht
habe warum es eigentlich dass nicht auch
zu mehr frauen in der medizin forschung
gibt hast du jemals auch das gefühl dass
ich mein anliegen sein sollte warum
immer er am männerkörper geforscht wird
um noch mal auf den koroma im schaft
zurückzukommen der ist glaube ich
ausgelegt für einen 85 kilo mann also
ich bekomme die gleiche dosis wie ein 85
kilo mann mit 180 mit 950 kilo das kann
ja schon mal nicht sein und neulich habe
ich mir die eu profen 601 gepfiffen und
ich war wirklich glatt ich hatte
kopfschmerzen und war nicht mehr ganz
herr meiner sinne und gefühle trifft
mich so eine 600 natürlich viel mehr der
arzt schreibt sie mir aber bei den
gleichen symptomen die mein mann hat da
ist meinen 85 kilo mann und da finde ich
finde es schon mal erschrecken wenn man
weiß dass beta-blocker bei frauen zum
beispiel viel mehr
herzrhythmusstörungen machen die
wirklich bedrohlich sind oder dass
blutverdünner oft nicht so gut wirken
und all diese sachen ja das war für mich
recherchearbeit weltweit das
zusammenzutragen um zu sagen leute wenn
ihr eure symptome stimmen vielleicht
nicht ja und irgendein auch
risikofaktoren sind frauen ganz anders
geht entschuldige i kenn di lacht sie
reden von wenn sie naturkunde sagen
reden sie von homöopathie und da wollte
ich sagen ist deutschland das einzige
land das das sozusagen durch die
solidargemeinschaft finanziert der
verstehen als blockierer meinung wird
sie wählt die naturheilkunde und
gesunden lebensstil und das was er sagt
ist natürlich erschrecken ich wusste das
ehrlich gesagt
ich hatte sehr interessant ich habe vor
einem jahr eine herzmuskelentzündung
diagnostiziert bekommen war lange im
krankenhaus und die war gottseidank
erste diagnostiziert als ich schon auf
dem abklingen ach was ich habe alles
unbeschadet überstanden nicht also trotz
hat man mir sehr starke betablocker
verschrieben die ich dann persönlich
gefährlicher als für männer ganz klar
ich habe sie abgesetzt nach wenigen
wochen weil ich einfach gespürt habe
mein herz flimmern wird stärker obwohl
diese entwicklung eigentlich aus gestand
typisches bei mainz wurde schwächer man
derzeit und dann hab ich auch union
hatte lunge entschieden schön hier und
nehmen sie sondern ihr buch heißt ich
finde das nicht so lange dankeschön die
bessere medizin für frauen und da steht
genauso was drin ja wenn man seine
symptome zum beispiel dass man die mal
richtig einordnen kann bei frauen haben
oft ganz andere symptome als männer
unsere organe sind ganz anders aber wir
sind ja hier verdammt viel langsamer ja
unsere unsere leber verstoffwechselt
dass also die schneller und das gehalt
erinnern dass das damals erst mal
festhalten dass er die ärztin hier im
viertel achten dass frauen als männer
sind ein ist sogar mehrere
es würde doch keiner sagen von uns in
fünf über 70 kilo oder unter oder oder
so oder so groß wir würden sagen hier
sitzen drei frauen und zwei männer aber
in der medizin wird das so nicht
beachtet und das ist ein unding weil am
ende kostet uns frauen menschleben größe
wesen der schweiz also wirkung sind die
männer auch verschieden von den frauen
das kommando habe ich fest der schweiz
und es gibt auch medikamente für mich
ist diese diskussion auch neu und ich
muss auch sagen das ist dennoch hoch
interessant ich meine in den usa können
sie nicht mehr einreisen mit dieser
these weil da gibt es keine unterschiede
mehr zwischen männern und frauen keine
biologische mehr keine physiologischen
ist
das ein soziales konstrukt körper ist
nur noch ein ausfluss unsere mentalen
obsessionen anderen ich das finde ich
zehnter sein weil ich ein bekennender
hypochonder bin und ich habe mich doch
ich sehe eigentlich super verein flügeln
auf alle nebenwirkungen wenn ich jetzt
das sagen was ich haben dass das härtet
mich jetzt geradezu ab wenn ich ihnen
zuhöre da sage ich die frau hier
sozusagen medikamente bekommen die alle
enden sozusagen rosskur mäßig erprobt
wurden so haben die nase über sich
ergehen das lasse ich datenlücken das
weiß ja keiner was heißt sind wären sie
ja ja denn natürlich jeder arzt weiß es
haben sie den rheumatologen der wirte
ihnen sagen die frauen vertragen
methotrexat viel viel schlechter als die
männer
woche ehrlich gesagt ja
in basel ist die apotheke europas ich
finde solche sollten dabei absolut nein
wir werden das werden das erweckte
einspeisen und das als neues
geschäftsmodell für die schweizer
pharmaindustrie hier verbringen weil wir
da müssen dass wir die kaution costa hat
ihn zum vorjahr so darf ich mal aber
nein die antibabypille habe ich
persönlich nie genommen weil ich mich
sehr mit der thematik auseinander setze
und ich empfinde sie als
gefährlich meine oder sind die besondere
wenn man sieht es dann in der
kombination mit rauchen was du ja heute
auch hatten als thema ist das nicht zu
unterschätzen
da wird mal wieder nach acht darf man
machen sagen man sonst nirgendwo sagen
frauen sind anders als männer ist
gefährlich deutlich für sich recht wohl
fühlen können aber wie kann
weil die pille ist auch ein segen
natürlich was wir ohne machen auf der
anderen seite das müssen wir viel
stärker die männer ins gebet länger
warum alles eher ein kölner richter